Did you know that you can make a route from italy to 100% land and making
one of the cheapest trips throughout europe starts in the north of italy
in a city like trieste or venice and is that from here it will only be
a couple of hours to get to liubliana the capital of eia.
Your tour will continue in Zagreb,
capital of Croatia,
from where you can escape to visit some of the most places of the country.
Continue north this time to visit budapest in hungary and
from here a land bus tour to Belgrade,
Serbian capital.
The route continues to in the capital of Romania and then to Sofia,
capital of Bulgaria,
and finally from here take a direct train connecting to Istanbul in Turkey.
I took this route in 25 days and it cost less than €900 or $1100
US which would be equivalent to 22,000 Mexican pesos.